i feel like these games will deserve a
lot of like analysis and reflection
um and like the breaks are longer
compared to normal but it feels still
very short so i'm three out of three
again closing the chat playing a london
yeah very short breaks
um who is this i know this person
oh go wayne jones oh gwayne jones very
strong
dwayne jones wrote a book on the grand
prix sicilian
which um yeah he was one of my favorite
players actually
like kind of growing up because he would
play these these um
kind of sharp offbeat openings at least
for like
strong gm level rosin gawain jones
we have five thousand sent to jews but
on rosen
and now he's he's gamuting some time
okay so maybe i'll reopen the chat say
hi to some people
um oh never mind okay let's uh stay
focused and let's play pitch by f4
playing in london against a british
person
i don't know see what he wants to do
against london against
whatever this is called i'm sure he's
prepared
yeah he's prepared we're going to go
into a line which
is really sharp and
yeah i'm already feeling like not super
comfortable i think queen c
queen d choose uh the move to play here
go eric rosen
show the british number two or three who
the boss is but probably him
it's a line that i really have to to
refine
a lot of strong players are playing the
seas
and then
i just want to keep things like somewhat
simple
there's some vague memory of taking and
bishop here
and some e4 i don't know if it works in
this position
it's so bad that like i'm already
thinking here
so i've had this position so many times
i just turn on the engine
engine like usually suggests queen d2
and then at some point taking the
i haven't played this enough to actually
like dig so deeply
because a lot of like a lot of other
lesser experienced players they allow h5
or they allow um this might be five move
i think there's some naka it's a knock a
nepo game
naka played some like bishop b5 and then
take some bishop e5
bishop b5 makes some some sense here
95 also move
party time excellent gawain's world
bishop d3 a move
go eric rosen america but okay it's like
slow chess or it's uh it's relatively
rapid chess i have to
just rely on some intuition
i'm kind of drawn to bishop bishop 594
and we trade actually trading looks okay
all right let's go for this so the idea
of this move is
to at some point take and then just
really control e5 nicely
ensuring that black doesn't get to play
e5
i mean there's sharp lines with knight
e4
i was thinking knight e4 i can take and
then take on c6
and then i'll have knight e4 oh but then
if e5 the line keeps going
probably just a mess
i guess yeah it's one of these lines
where
i'm not like super theoretically
prepared but at least i
i remember some ideas i've seen some
strong player games
there's another match i think it was
some speed chess championship
maybe aronian vs nappo aronian was
playing this a lot
i actually covered covered like maybe
one or two of these lines
um in my my london course at least like
these middle game positions where
tactics occur
i think aronian was getting to play h5
and then take and their tactics along
the diagonal
which is not the case in this position
so he plays knight e4 so um
i looked at this briefly takes takes
takes
and queen can't take on d2 because i
take with knight
it's still possible i guess
so knight takes e4 i mean i guess this
is most
likely and then knight d4 and then i i
guess i do have to be ready for
for e5 takes queen c7
which might just be losing for me
so takes takes takes
another option actually okay because i
am temporarily up upon
is to just give a pawn back
um because yeah okay let's look at this
one more time knight d4 e5
take c6 queen c7
not seeing much so the idea would be to
take on
on d8 first rook takes and then
and then knight d4 and then e5 then
taking on c6 should work
um the drawback of this that allows
takes takes takes
and some balance obstacle bishops
probably not worse there bishop e3
okay let's go for it don't think black
ever has time to take on b2
another option is taking and taking
right away can transpose
um
yes in that case i'm not giving away my
bishop
yeah let's just stick with what i i
looked at
so again 95 okay i'm checking this one
more time because knight d4 e5 there is
bishop g5 but
f6 might take c6 queen c7
wait a minute i have queen d5 in that
line
oh wait but okay this obviously doesn't
work cause queen takes d2
just missing things
yeah there's no no bishop takes d2
unfortunately
um so yeah let's not waste more time
and this i'm just double checking e5
doesn't
doesn't work yeah so e5 i i counter
attack the rook
i assume that's okay e5 takes there's
takes takes takes
um but my knight's not getting trapped
there's rook here i guess bishop c3
king bishop c3
and king can't move to e2
black might go for that actually it's
very sharp
yeah the problem is my king doesn't have
a a great square
one more time here here here
here here and there's castling king's
side
stacking back the exchange
now i'm actually not down pawns because
i lost b2 but i won c6
yeah so if we go into this i'm um
i'm probably just going to give back the
exchange in castle and then allow this
and then now it's just a mess he plays
bishop a6 so now
okay e5 is always a concern
um
probably a wise move
where's bishop maybe just simple bishop
g3
but then admin takes
if i castle
there's also knight takes c6 here it
just looks really dangerous
what's his idea knight takes c6 bishop
takes b2
[Music]
c3
gc3 is interesting c3 e5 and then i take
gets two bishops but i have pawns
a very short position
what else to play bishop so i didn't
like bishop g3 because then black
just takes
maybe it's still playable
rook d1
yeah rook do you want how bad could it
be rook t8 takes takes bishop f4
i guess i lose a pawn
it's very possible i'll just have like a
pawn down obstacle bishop ending
i'm looking for something better here
takes on c6
bishop c7 now
let's look at this one more time takes
wait what was the line
oh yeah it was queenside castling i'm
just forgetting takes
go america the grand master has the two
bee shops
what else
oh maybe i just miscalculated before
let's play this
that's not what i wanted
it feels like i'm just getting outplayed
nice thing is okay the bishop controls
b8 so
yeah this is still still some issue
have to trade off a pair of rooks
and yeah the problem the problem is this
idea
was expecting rook d8 it probably makes
more sense
so c3 only move
i want to play rook t7 he played c3
when he loses the game he'll be po'd
very bad play from rose in the last five
moves
went from better to completely lost
frankly terrible okay the king belongs
on c1
the rook wants to to join in either on
d1 or e1
[Music]
that's a move like once you see it you
just realize that you're going down
that's so sad i can't take on e7 because
then i'm just getting mated
that's really sad good move so i have to
suffer here
um yeah there's very little hope
i'll try though i mean obstacle bishops
f6 good move bishop c7
i don't even know what to play here eric
rosen playing for a draw
will he achieve it the answer is fries
i guess here the bishop doesn't want to
get stuck
bishop's kind of in no man's land but if
e5 it would have gotten stuck
so maybe i have some like b4
[Music]
plant the bishop on c5
so this is my plan to plant the bishop
on c5 play b4 a4 and then have a two
two against one majority and then hope
probably have to pray that black doesn't
make like six queens
but there's no past pawns yet i mean
their d4 can be coming
okay so at least i'm getting what i want
even though this was not what i
originally wanted but okay the
the pawn is is still kind of um a bit
tender on a7 so the rook
can't yet activate and this is a plan
have to think happy thoughts a5 might
come
it's not a happy thought a6 good move
like rook h3 to g3
what else to do
i could play g3 maybe in g3 and
it looks weird g3 probably doesn't make
sense
play this and try and make him worry
but it's it's unfortunate i'm down on
time and i have a bad position
so my time would probably be my one hope
but i'm just down close to three minutes
it's pandemonium over here yeah
shoot a little crossfire there you like
that moment
damn looking bad for rosen
i knew from the day he was born he was
bad so
at this point i probably have to play
the waiting game
and just play quick moves and hope that
he
kind of drains his time
yeah d4 could also be coming
let's go back i guess d4 i just ignore
everything
but ignoring things that's like
that's like staying at home when katrina
is coming
like a massive hurricane i could take
hmm
so okay at least i have a simple
tactical threat please blunder i mean
king d5 is coming
yeah and f4 also coming wow
i'm getting squashed
in g3 trying to slow down some pawn
storm
these pawns are so strong and black's
doing really
doing a really good job at controlling
the center
[Music]
the thing is i'm only down the pawn
feels like i'm down like three pawns
and i have no counter play on the queen
side he wants to play rook f7
very wise
if i take i just want to have tactics
maybe king here king doesn't want to be
on the light square
but let's try it
you just want to i want to try something
and if i provoke d3 then the bishop is
actually sort of useful
because then it covers f2 it's probably
a good move
a very good move
let's try this
thanks for subbing pack all right rosa
with no time and no position
frankly terrible
it's the beating of a lifetime rosen had
a good position
and then he didn't yeah the problem is
i'm
like rook of chu's gonna be coming
it's not exactly possible to stop
can i take takes
probably just getting mated there let's
try this
good move
yeah everything everything is just
crumbling here
[Music]
it's a sad move
i tried to resist i mean three out of
four will still not be
such a disastrous score got one upset
obviously at this point i'm just hoping
for stalemate tricks
so sack all the things
six seconds left eric rosen not
resigning
playing for some stalemate trick that
won't work
ooh there's a meeting idea there is a
mating idea
oh it doesn't work though he moved his
bishop oh it's almost neat
i resigned good game
oh that's tough got out played you
played well i don't know
i should like don't know offhand where i
went wrong
man when dwayne jones wins he really
wins like plus a thousand maybe like
grabbing the pawn maybe taking on c6
also yeah hello to everyone in the chat
if you're just if you're joining and you
you're confused
i'm playing in the the may chess mayhem
it's a tournament organized by ben
feingold
and karen and it's super strong it's a
seven round
swiss event that was just round four
and three out of four um
yeah it's been i think it's it's been
high quality games
like this game i'm not really too
disappointed about it
it is kind of painful to just struggle
in a
a bad position you went wrong by playing
london against a brit
that's fair i liked
i i thought i was doing okay here i
didn't think i was worse
this was a really strong move though
because it prevented me from castling
and it put me in a situation where
like i have to deal with e5 and taking
on c6
i don't think worked
let's see just get some
really quick feedback
computer likes 95.
um i can't always trust the engine
knight e5 actually makes a lot more
sense here though because it doesn't
lose a pawn
it's just a move that i guess there's
knight c4 ideas too
it does everything basically that knight
d4 does that just doesn't lose upon